we have a number lined with tick marks  for X 0 Y and Z the tick marks on the  number line are evenly spaced which of  the following statements must be true  the product of X Y and Z is less than  zero X Plus Z is equal to Y and Z  multiplied by y minus X is greater than  zero let's work this out  since the tick marks are evenly spaced  we know the distance between each tick  mark is equal to Y so the tick mark for  Z is going to be at 2y and the tick mark  for X will be at negative y now the  first statement is the product of x y  and z y and z are positive numbers and X  is a negative number so we know this is  going to be less than zero then X Plus Z  will be equal to negative y plus 2y  which is equal to Y finally Z is a  positive number and Y minus a negative  number will also be a positive number so  this product will also be positive  therefore we know all three statements  are true and the correct answer is e